but what is the difference between the
standard deviation and the variance as
we now know the standard deviation is
the quadratic mean of the distance from
the mean the variance now is the squared
standard deviation so we have one at the
same equation the only difference is
that in order to calculate the standard
deviation we take the root and in order
to calculate the variance we don't
because the root is taken the standard
deviation is always in the same unit as
the original data in our case
centimeters for this reason it is
advisable to always use the standard
deviation to describe data as this makes
interpretation easier the variance is
more difficult to interpret because the
unit is the square of the original unit
in our case centimeters squared